I'm Gregg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
rundown
Wednesday July 1st 2020 I'm Dave Anthony
it's almost four months till Election
Day and despite the corona crisis and
racial unrest former House Speaker Newt
Gingrich is still confident about a
trump reelection this is the most
disruptive president since Andrew
Jackson he terrifies the left I'm Chris
Foster
it's right there on the Constitution
every ten years Americans are asked to
come forward to be counted and this year
we want people to understand that
responding to the census has never been
more important given where we are and
how things have have transpired over the
past couple of months and I'm Robert
Jeffress I've got the final word on the
Fox News rundown
it's summer and the presidential
campaign is heating up 18 weeks before
Election Day Joe Biden came out swinging
the president gives no direction and he
pits us against one another we can't
continue like this calling the Trump
coronavirus response a failure and it
seems like our wartime president
surrendered waved the right fly what
white flag who left the battlefield and
the presumed Democratic nominee reacted
to the new rush of controversy Intel
reports that Moscow tried to pay the
Taliban to kill US soldiers in
Afghanistan the president says he never
got that intelligence it was deemed not
credible Biden says if he was briefed
and did nothing
the public should unrelated to my
running conclude this man didn't fit to
be President I'm States of America the
president often calls Biden sleepy Joe
saying there's something wrong with him
watch me and I can hardly wait to
compare my cognitive capability to that
cognitive capability of the man I'm vice
president committed to three debates
this fall and Newt Gingrich expects it
will be a tough fight for president
Trump I think he will get really good
but I think it's a real serious
knock-down drag-out situation it's not
it's not automatic and it's not easy the
former House speaker has a new book out
Trump and the American future and he
also has a new special on Fox Nation
crisis 2020 I think you have to be
concerned when you go through the
Chinese virus the government imposed
depression people in are under lockdown
on happily and then with the tragic
killing of George Floyd and the
demonstrations leading to riots and
meeting there's a lot of things going on
when I first broke my new book Trump in
the American future I finished it at the
end of February when things were
amazingly good Louis black unemployment
rate in history Louis Hispanic
unemployment rate in history everything
seemed to be working and then BOOM the
Chinese wire showed up everything fell
apart and I had to go back and rewrite
parts of the book over the book Lucy so
yeah well it's actually interesting when
you read it because I as I write this in
March as I write
as the coronavirus takes hold it added
an extra element of uncertainty that you
didn't expect obviously we're gonna have
to learn to manage the virus because you
can't close down you know the largest
economy in the world for three years or
whatever like whatever length of time
the public health people will figure out
so you need to learn how to manage it
and in fact if you read beliefs the
newspaper headlines
things are getting substantially better
obviously it's not easy for any
president to be re-elected with a bad
economy George HW Bush found that out of
1992 if the economy doesn't recover as
quickly in a v-shape as a lot of the
president's advisors are saying it will
will that be a real problem for him
October and then early November but
people don't have to see it having fully
recovered but they have to see a trend
line that indicates it will recover and
I think that I think frankly is a pretty
good chance that's going to happen I
think what you have right now and I just
noticed the thing the consumer
confidence came in substantially higher
that people expected and I think we're
seeing the housing sales go up much
faster than people expected so I think
you may see a lot of pent up energy and
pent up drive I personally think that
they ought to pass a one year holiday on
the payroll tax and the other pants 100
percent expensing so businesses could
modernize and bring all their
manufacturing back from China is that I
would like to see that done just as an
insurance policy to accelerate the rate
of growth but I think I think if people
think that we're coming back then
they're gonna say you know Trump is much
better at this than Biden if it looks
like we're not coming back then I think
Trump has a different this is another
big issue
[Applause]
weeks of protests flag-burning tearing
down monuments and statues calling for
racial justice an effort to reform
policing stalled though at the Senate
our effort was a sincere effort
authentic effort based on true
discussions with african-american
leaders and law enforcement Republican
senator Tim Scott urge Democrats to
compromise but after they passed their
own bill in the House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said this whole thing of
equivalence why can't you work together
because they don't share our values on
this subject not yet but I hope that
they will some communities are taking up
the protesters cause like New York City
cutting the police budget Newt Gingrich
is a big know on that the country
understands that the idea of defunding
the police makes no sense at all when
you watch for example in New York the
worst mayor in the country
de Blasio with people record number of
people being shot last week in New York
City he decides he's going to cut the
police budget by a billion dollars and
not hire 1,300 policemen who were in the
pipeline or supposed to get hurt now
that's just crazy and I think the
average American knows when you look at
a week of looting and violence in
Minneapolis and then they decided to
cancel the police department I think the
average person thinks that that's just
madness and there's no evidence that the
average American thinks defunding the
police is a rational strategy the
president through this process in before
getting back to what happened with
Charlotte's ville the president has been
called by Democrats who are in Congress
a racist or a white supremacist he's
been called a bigot you write in your
book about the language that the
president and deals with and has to
battle in his fight for re-election I'm
assuming that's going to happen and
continue to happen it was a very simple
premise this is the most disruptive
president since Andrew Jackson he
terrifies the left when he gets 300
judges confirmed the average left winger
goes crazy they hate him unfortunately a
large quarter
the propaganda media that used to be
news media hates him and you saw things
like the New York Times where they
published one column by a conservative
senator and the editor got fired for
publishing one column you know so I
think it's amazing the Trump has been
able to stay standing there is a big
rethinking though of the people from
founding fathers all the way up until
Woodrow Wilson for instance being his
name taken off of a school at Princeton
there's a big rethinking of those men
and and that they were either racists or
bigots or or or acknowledging those
kinds of things so where do you stand on
that I think most of it's crazy
yeah nobody's perfect but George
Washington was the extraordinary leader
of great moral courage on whom the
entire nation stands this was the first
country to say the Euro rights come
directly to you from God and we have
spent the last 200 year 240 years
expanding that only to include everybody
so we are we're not a perfect country
but we're countries seeking to improve
the lives of everyone now the critics
say that Washington and Jefferson owned
slaves and that's and they did and they
should be condemned 490 and theirs they
did yeah but look it's hard for me to
deal with this rationally because I
think they're so stupid if you go back
in history and you decide that you're
going to apply this week standards all
right at some point in the near future
will occur to the gay pride movement
though we should take down the statues
of everybody who favor traditional
marriage and then I'm sure the
transgender wing of that movement will
decide we should take down everybody who
didn't a fully appreciate and understand
being transgender and you go down the
list I mean what is it where does it
stop I was born in Pennsylvania my
relatives fought in the Union Army I
grew up in an integrated US Army the
first bill I sponsor when I went to
Congress was Martin Luther King's
birthday
so I'm not saying any of this out of
indifference or out of life of concern
but but to then jump from that to taking
down Washington statue I think is
historically so destructive and so crazy
that it's very hard for me to deal with
it rationally or in your book you wrote
there's one thing every republican needs
to understand in 2020 the unending media
hostility is not a problem it is a fact
what we do about it is the problem any
Republican who doesn't start out every
morning knowing that the news media will
be totally against you is just making a
huge mistake think of it it's the
equivalent of having a sailboat and
knowing that you're always gonna go into
a headwind
so you just have to learn how to attack
and have again around it the media says
it's the president who is playing loose
with the facts they have a counter that
the talks of thousands of times that
he's lied or made misstatements on
Twitter at other places the president of
course loves to tweet it does get him in
trouble sometimes right no I told him I
told him personally I like about the 10%
less Trump would be a hundred percent
more effective listen to you no of
course not he looked he looked at me and
said are you talking about my tweets I
said yes I said I like about 80 percent
of them he said no no it's going to be
95 when he gets into the fall and he
goes head to head with Joe Biden what do
you think his strategy should be to talk
consistently about the Biden schumer
pelosi machine and how radical they
would be if they had power and what they
would try to do and to take up HR 6800
which is the three trillion dollar
pelosi bill which has so much radical as
a minute that you could spend the whole
fall campaign just in that one bill and
just I'll just give you one example in
207 Democrats voted for it it includes a
provision to give every single illegal
immigrant 1200 dollars as a stimulus now
I don't think they're very many
districts United States I think we need
to give the illegal immigrants
hundred dollars the real danger from the
standpoint of most Americans is what
having a Democratic Senate Democratic
House Democratic White House they would
turn the country into some some cross
between California and Seattle the polls
have showed Biden in the lead the
president has called the polls a joke I
was campaigning with George HW Bush when
he was nineteen points behind Dukakis
anyone um so you know just depends so
you're not worried about any of the
polls now no no I'm not worried about
the polls now I think the polls tell you
over the combination of you Biden being
allowed to hide with the news media
carefully avoiding asking any
embarrassing questions well every
morning they figure out every possible
way to attack the president and as you
pointed out in the middle of in the
middle of the virus the government
induced depression have people haven't
been isolated into some sense to us and
substantial unrest including looting and
violence and you know I think all of
that makes it harder for the incumbent
to make the case it's if it's a
referendum on Trump it might win I mean
he might lose if it's a choice between
Trump and a Biden Pelosi Schumer team I
suspect to win by surprising module the
book is Trump and the American future
solving the great problems of our time
for former House Speaker Newt Gingrich
also there's a new special on Fox Nation
crisis 2020 speaker thank you very much
for joining us again thank you
[Music]
this is Robert Jeffress with your
FoxNews commentary
coming up it's that time every 10 years
when Americans are counted to determine
representation in Congress and where a
lot of federal money goes among other
things there's a push on to encourage
people to take part in the census still
a lot of counting to do with workers
going door to door coronavirus or not a
lot of Americans have already taken it
upon themselves to participate many of
them online most if not all households
across the country actually have been
invited to respond to the substance and
as of today 61.7% that's nearly 62
percent of all households across the
country across our nation have responded
to the 2020 census Michael Cook is chief
of the public information office at the
US census based on our estimates for
self-response we are ahead of where we
were or where we have planned to be
rather at this point in the campaign but
we are dogged and laser point
laser focus rather on ensuring that
everybody knows that the census is still
being conducted you still have an
opportunity to respond and the best
response is a self-response and we'd
like people to respond as soon as
possible
not that you want people to wait but
people do have a little more time now
write your deadlines move our deadline
has moved there are a number of
operations that we've adjusted due to
the ongoing pandemic and our
self-response period has been extended
October 31st of this year but mind you
the non-response follow-up why should
say the door-knocking which people are
familiar with when we talk about you
know census workers coming to the door
that type of follow-up with houses who
haven't responded will commence it will
start this summer and during that period
people can still self respond that's the
beauty of and the resilience of our
campaign this decade that it's
constructed in a way where there is an
ability to respond online for the
duration of the campaign but it's it's
our jobs to help let people know the
value beyond respond by responding you
know you
your local community when it comes to
power and money political representation
in all levels of government including
the House of Representatives and local
elected officials but then also services
that come down and are used and utilized
by informed decisions based on a
complete and accurate count of counting
everybody wants all he wants and in the
right place so the decision makers can
make informed decisions that impact the
lives of the people that live in local
communities so it's important for people
to respond early knowing that we have to
October 31st to respond but being a good
steward of taxpayers dollars I need to
encourage everybody to respond and to
respond early talk about you started to
you did a little bit the benefits to
someone's community for anybody who
might say why bother for example who
stands to win and lose House seats this
time around well you know part of the
process or the the outgrowth of benefits
of responding to the census I alluded to
it earlier is power and we talked about
power that's political representation
and for those who aren't steeped in how
the government works there is a count of
all of the residents that live in the
United States every 10 years every year
that ends in a zero it's required by the
US Constitution article 1 section 2
those responses are then used to shape
decisions of how billions of dollars in
federal state and local funds are spent
in your community for the next 10 years
so it's not about this being an impact
that that is just for here now but it's
for 10 years so a non-response or I
should say an inaccurate count of
anybody that lives in your local area
will in fact an impact or negatively
impact the federal funding for for local
hospitals schools the emergency services
whether you're talking about rural
communities where it's grants for
farmers and for Block Grants and and
things of that nature whether it's for
students who are receiving Pell grants
so it touches every single facet of our
society and our nation and our
neighborhoods our state and our
community now comes the hard part which
becomes a little bit harder if not a lot
harder because of the outbreak there are
going to be people who
may be reluctant to have contact what
are you doing to protect workers what
are you doing to make respondents feel
safe right now when you look at the
response and and the fact that people
need to respond and and how they respond
and and who's assisting us with that
response of the census is yours the
census is not an operation and we're
actually doing and making you do the
census is actually the power is in your
hand it's in your your your is your
ability to stand up and to respond and
to be counted is really where the rubber
meets the road we want people to
understand that responding to the census
has never been more important given
where we are and how things have have
transpired over the the past couple of
months we are providing training for all
of our staff that at one point or at
some point may be in your neighborhood
we're ensuring that we're following all
of the guidance all of the the local
mandates when it comes to protecting not
only our staff but protecting those that
they come into contact with or those
those neighborhoods that they're
actually going across and and knocking
on doors and coming into contact with
their rpps that we've issued to them
there is training that we've provided to
them as well as the communications that
communications to the to the communities
let them know that it's okay to open
your doors and it's okay to come into
contact with census employees that's
going to be critical
Michael for history fans out there talk
about just how long this has been
happening it's almost the census is
almost as old as the nation this census
because it is in the Constitution that
would lead one to think that it is
something that is steeped in in
tradition 1790 was the very first census
that was conducted and back in 1790
obviously it wasn't conducted the way it
is now there were US Marshals who
traversed across the country to
homesteads and the homes and households
and they enumerated households they
observed and took account of what they
saw and filled out forms accordingly the
power of the census not only is that
I think we have the technology in place
to ensure an accurate and complete count
more over than we had in the past and we
fine-tuned all of our processes and
procedures but now in the in these times
responding to the census is something
that the actual residents of the United
States do
it's about self-response it's about you
identifying who you are and telling us
what race you are what ethnicity you are
it's not us observing and then filling
out a form as if we know exactly what
what in who you are so the census
through the decades it does change it
shows the population how it shifts how
it grows those dynamics and information
that we collect for those genealogists
who are very weighting interested with
bated breath waiting for our next census
to be released the 1950 census is going
to be release in 2022 we have a rule in
place it's a 72 year rule so 72 years
after we actually collect the data we
actually we don't actually do it it's
National Archives it does it they
actually release that information
records and all so that genealogists
family members people that want to look
at the history of the United States that
snapshot 72 years prior can take a look
and see how their household or how their
community responded to the census during
that decade well it's really interesting
that 72 year old I have a lot of
genealogist amateur genealogist size
family and friends and they'll be happy
to hear about that that news in a couple
of years one more thing you guys also do
your best to count the homeless
population how do you do it well you
know the homeless population and all
populations are important for us to
count the homeless population every
decade there's a couple of nights out of
the during the cycle where we actually
Traverse across the country and work
closely with local jurisdictions to help
identify those those cases where the
homeless population does reside where
they usually sleep the the tent cities
we work with soup kitchens and other
type of facilities that house people who
are experiencing homelessness we do
continue to
look into and to evaluate on a
case-by-case basis state-by-state basis
community by community basis how we will
do that operation but there are plans
for us to conduct that operation this
decade regardless of the situation
ongoing situational cope in nineteen not
only did you get breathing room as far
as responses goes you have some
breathing room in terms of delivery of
the data we're not going to get it at
the end of the year it's gonna be
probably now April thirtieth I guess the
White House will get those numbers so um
a little too a little delayed but as
required by the Constitution there's
going to be a 2020 census Michael cook
chief of the public information office
at the US Census Bureau Michael thanks
for coming on the fox news rundown
thanks for having me and anybody who
wants to know more please visit 2020
census go for more information and if
you haven't responded please respond as
soon as you can
[Music]
download and subscribe to original
podcast from Fox News radio it's time to
get caught up on what's happened and
what's next I'm Jared Halpern from
Washington subscribe and listen now by
going to Fox News podcast calm Rayden
review the fox news rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your fox news commentary Robert
Jeffress what's on your mind
this past Sunday our church the First
Baptist Church in Dallas hosted our
annual celebrate freedom worship service
the Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development dr. ben Carson was here as
well as Senator John Cornyn and governor
Greg Abbott but the honored guest who
brought the message was our vice
president Mike Pence he delivered a
refreshing message of hope in the midst
of what have been some of our nation's
darkest days the Vice President the
public servant coordinating the federal
government's response to the corona
virus made clear that his hope comes not
from his own wisdom or even from the
great strength and material prosperity
of our country instead his hope comes
from the personal faith in the Lord
Jesus Christ
he found as a teenager on a rainy
evening in Kentucky mice President Pence
heard the good news that God the Father
soul of the Simsek world that he sent
His only begotten Son to give us eternal
life I for one heartily agree with what
the vice president said about our
nation's historic formula for success
the foundation of America is freedom and
the foundation of freedom is faith
America simply would not have come to
exist were it not for its strong
commitment to freedom and the freedom
our nation has enjoyed for so long would
not have continued to exist were it not
for its strong commitment to faith this
has been true for our nation's history
and it remains true for our nation's
future so many forces in our country
work against faith and seek to undermine
it an aggressive secularism seeks to
religion from the public schools the
public square and from our public
servants that would spell disaster for
our nation as alexis de tocqueville
observed america is great because
America is good if America ever ceases
to be good America will cease to be
great and we can only be good when we
have a saving encounter with Jesus
Christ when we're healed from our sinful
desires by the Holy Spirit and when were
reconciled to God the Father in heaven
that's the kind of transformation our
nation needs one life at a time
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love Fox News
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes